I recently told somebody that getting
attacked by a shark was the greatest
thing that's ever happened to me they're
like that's absurd with that you know
why would you say that I've had
incredible opportunities I've been able
to visit some really cool places and be
some incredible people all these things
have been nurtured from the shark attack
I think it's really made me who I am
today
my name is Mike coots I live in Island
of Hawaii in Hawaii I'm a surfer
photographer and shark attack survivor
there's some really great surf spots out
here I was eighteen years old
surfing here on Kauai II with some
friends and it was early in the morning
and I paddled out and thought I was
gonna have a surf session like any other
day and it was a lot different I got
attacked by a tiger shark as soon as I
hit it it let go and disappeared back
underwater and I remember passing out
basically as soon as we got to the
hospital and I woke up a day and a half
later and a PT I got my first prosthetic
six months after the shark attack early
on you think you can't do this you think
you can't do that you know there's these
physical limitations on life and I don't
think I could drive a truck with a stick
shift and you learn how to drive a truck
with a stick shift and you're like wow
that was cool and you build up these
little things like day to day to day
after a while it's like bring it on what
what can happen that I can't figure out
how to do I was in college and I
remember class got out I was like you
know what I'm gonna take a longboard I'm
gonna get the biggest board I could find
and just take my prosthetic in the water
and see what happens I caught a wave and
I was screaming pretty loud I was like
this is cool this is amazing and I think
that was like the best wave had ever
caught on my light from then on I
started figure out okay what's gonna
break what can I make that's a foot
that'll help me surf even better and
trying to basically make the ultimate
surfing foot I think I'm doing it
because it's fun but I'm also it's this
learning experience and it's taking this
information and passing it on to people
that want to surf with a prosthetic
the ocean has taken a lot for me but
what it's given back to me has been
immeasurable
I've lost you know nearly my life to a
shark yet
I really believe sharks are one of the
if not the most important species in
term or an ecosystem at the rate that
they're being killed off they're not
going to be around in 10 15 20 years and
why not use something that could I guess
be set as a negative and and turn into a
positive the shark attacks been the
greatest thing that's ever happened
you